in five the sound of your frog the sound
of your [ __ ] fro four three two one
hello everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast I'm
your host David so this is a podcast
about everything and anything and you're
just gonna hear a bunch of people talk
about [ __ ] then maybe you want to go
ahead and put your opinions on because
honestly your opinions matter do I care
about it absolutely not
but they matter just some matter to
somebody out there man and conversations
are great you know what I realized was
great about podcasts at a certain point
I stopped I stopped listening to music
Isis the podcast now oh I thought you
were going to say you stopped listening
to me and that too I'm gonna [ __ ] about
what you're saying no yeah I stopped
listening to music really yeah I just
started listening to podcast like when I
go so I do these like daily walks and on
those daily walks I saw it listen to
music I just listen to podcast now what
are your favorite podcasts the Joe Rogan
experience okay Tiger belly shoutouts to
Tiger belly's Gilbert [ __ ] wide faced
[ __ ] you talking about a Gucci ass face
trucker that's this whole Gilbert has
like a size 8 head dude his head is huge
if he head-butted you you'd be dead
concussed Gilbert we love you I don't
don't speak those - David apparently
over dude stupid ass Gilbert and his
stupid big-ass head that fool makes my
head look small dude that is gigantic a
small gust of wind and he will topple
over it's just because he also has like
a big head of hair - no it's not his
head of hair it's the size of his noggin
that [ __ ] is crazy he looks like a meat
mallet oh gosh Gilbert I'm trying to
stand up for you here but David makes
some very strong points mallet I've got
a meat mallet you ever see that [ __ ]
wooden hammer that kids [ __ ] play
with the huggin that's what his head
look like is crazy dude she's [ __ ]
insane man a rubber no Gilbert's great
dude actually Gilbert is actually one of
my favorite cast members in Tiger belly
I think he has like
just the right amount of humor and if it
was anybody else on that podcast they
would not work because Gilbert knows how
to like maneuver around the craziness
and Tiger belly
hmm yeah there's a lot of wild
characters on the [ __ ] Gilbert is mad
talented ooh yes like in terms of just
like his improv his comedy and on top of
that he could do like bunch of stunts
and tricks which I'm super sizing his
head is so big so when he does flips it
[ __ ] I would think it would make it turn
over too many times [ __ ] giant this
is just Gilbert praise right now these
are high high remarks coming from you
David so because I feel like I rarely
hear you speak so highly about a
compliment they'll [ __ ] out of people
dude I talk I guess people up like a
mother [ __ ] dude
it's just that sometimes when I talk
about people I don't like that that
flame is big right but it's not a lot of
people I dislike you my favorite people
feng bros these fangirls man like these
dude they're there dude baby I've never
met them dude there let me tell you
something others guys man they go out
there and they [ __ ] they do stuff man
fang bros man check them out that's so
vague and i've gotten absolutely nothing
gained no dude they'll tell you
everything there is to be about asian
person man why are you saying with yeah
man like the difference between like a
yeast chengqi i aged into a west [ __ ]
eyes asian dude they're so they're
pushing us forward man i like it
shoutouts to the thing already okay oh
dude do you don't even know I don't
clearly I don't Arnold and Danny man
shoutouts to you guys do but and Gilbert
I [ __ ] love you
no Berta I really I really do love
Gilbert it's like one of my like closest
guy friends for sure he kills it man
just to see like his come up to and how
he stuck it out with Tiger belly too and
look people don't realize like how
important he is to that oh for sure like
they don't they don't understand man
like I said dude like he's just like
that right amount of comedy yeah [ __ ]
love him I agree like Gilbert always I
get really annoyed because he'll always
be like oh is that Amanda sook famous
blogger vlogger on Instagram like style
maven Yaya le he'll just like hype
or gasps Mia for no reason but then like
what he doesn't know is that I actually
have like people hit me up in my DMS bit
like whenever I like put Gilbert on my
story they're like oh my god you know
Gilbert like fanning out over Gilbert
and I'm just like see you don't even
know I could be gassing you up right now
but I'm just not blowing you they just
want they just want his succulent little
[ __ ] lechon lips dude it's taken by
my dear friend Cindy oh he has a
girlfriend that yes indeed I went to
high school I love them oh yeah
random fact what the [ __ ] small world
same ages uh
two years I think to use blue I love
Cindy she's so funny yeah dude that's
crazy what a small [ __ ] world did
Gilbert Gilbert snot from that's from
Aunt Lana Georgia I would have never
thought we have such parallel lives I
think that's why we get along because he
was also like one of the few Asians but
not like in a way where he was ridiculed
for being Asian then he's also like I
feel like I don't know it'd be different
growing up Filipino cuz it's like you're
they probably just thought he was
Mexican or some [ __ ] maybe gone from
that [ __ ] cuz I had a friend to like had
he still is my friend he tells he said
the story where he originally went to
like an all-white school right and so he
would be made fun of for being in the
Asian kid all right they were like poke
fun at him for being Asian and really
[ __ ] so his parents took him out of
that school he went to another school
right and then they were just clowning
them for cuz they thought he was Mexican
so he was like being made fun of for
being an Asian kid then the [ __ ] like
the weird Mexican kid just like Dawg
like what the [ __ ] is going on right now
man you know it is what it is dude
shoutouts to Gilbert bro I love you your
head shaped like a Lego it's [ __ ]
beautiful meat mallet Lego hey bro
where's your way to poo pillow oh where
is that [ __ ] oh I don't know it's a
[ __ ] hit
I missed oh that's the thing that was
missing the most cuz everybody else
would have these gray pillows and I
would have the Winnie the Pooh pillow
just to like make it clear that you're
special
did you yes exactly that's exactly what
it was but back on the top of me
praising people I do praise a lot of
people let's shout out some people right
now you sure you should
you shout out somebody right now besides
making batoon Wow because you always
hear call out cuz you always shout her
out did good oh I know I know what dude
she's like my longest friend in LA yeah
but stop shouting her out all right like
I [ __ ] get it I will shout out my two
of my favorite boys Wes and Justin I've
been hanging out with them a lot this
year wesley chan and justin min what do
i yeah you go hiking well why not I
appreciate them boo boo boo a bit okay
so Wesley Chan from Wong foo Justin min
from now Umbrella Academy and he will
soon be in a movie called after yang
which was directed by Koga nada
who did finding in Columbus it's fine
well I've been friends with both of them
separately for many years but like for
whatever reason we recently have been
hanging out altogether more frequently
as I said and it's just been it's been
fun and it's been great do man I'm
saying this right now and I'm putting
this out to Wesley Wesley gets the [ __ ]
wet know about that [ __ ] Wesley gets the
[ __ ] wet I've never seen so many
[ __ ] Asian girls fangirl over Wesley
dudes and Wesley is one of those dudes
so unassuming unassuming man right now
if he wasn't a noble man this
[ __ ] would be Slavoj [ __ ] like
he's a dragon's thing this like ice ice
it's like he's like a kpop started he's
a little Chinese girls dude they come to
be like oh my god wes is so cute is you
know he's mysterious as [ __ ] yes he
looks like Chinese spock you don't know
what kind of spills he got dude we tease
him all the time
no but he's also just a fantastic guy he
really is ladies he's you know as he say
yeah he's single is ankle he got too
much to choose
I understand why you guys are all
fawning over him dude he got something
about him that girls love I don't know
what it's the quality that I don't have
he's very mysterious that's what it is I
think because he doesn't put so much of
himself out there it's like wait we
should who are you who's the real Wes I
need to know and he was a cool last name
it's like you were trying to spell West
but his parents just forgot the [ __ ]
letter dude whis you know what I think
girls probably also are attracted by
because he's so good with the camera so
like they know that they'll get some
like good shots of themselves some good
dick nasty I'm not the one saying all
these things David Wong foo more like
dog food I just imagine if Wes is
listening to this he's gonna be blushing
so what is hung like African zebra
firsthand doc I saw we went hiking once
he tripped over and he was I'm dead he
scratched my back with his big one wow
we're walking oh I feel I like I'm just
a picturing Wes listening to this and I
just feel so bad for him you know justin
is really cute too I actually cast you
to put a small little like Korean thing
that I did didn't come out it was
[ __ ] terrible a lot of money it was a
while back I actually still have the
script I just still like the script I
just haven't had the time to redo but
didn't know that he never told me that
doesn't did a great job dude he's cute
dude yeah they're bees a little cute yes
and Wes are both very handsome men and I
always joke about how I'm the third
wheel in this friendship and they get
mad at me for self-deprecating myself
would you be the third wheel they you
know bromance is just a really real
thing yeah so I mean I can't I can't
fight bromance but I will take credit
for that friendship happening
hello everybody this podcast is brought
to you by skill share now who loves
lifelong learning who else loves
learning at their own pace
who likes learning the things that they
want to learn outside of a regular
school curriculum well skill share is
there for you because check it out with
skill share man I'm telling you right
now if there are things out there that
you have hobbies for that you want to
learn skill share has an amazing digital
library of lessons that can teach you
what you want to learn for me skill sure
has been helping me out with editing see
I'm a you guys may think that I know
everything about editing videos I don't
I absolutely do not there's always so
much more that I can learn and I was
never never never never good at learning
in school at a desk with somebody else
tell me how I should learn well
Skillshare my friends has an amazing
library full of knowledge for you to
pick and choose from for the skills that
you want to learn you thought I was
gonna say share and that would have been
a great little joke but I'm not going to
on top my skills you are trying to learn
well you can join the million of
students I'm talking about millions of
students already learning on Skillshare
today with a special offer just for my
listeners get two months of Skillshare
for free that's right Skillshare is
offering genius brain listen there's two
months of unlimited access to thousands
of classes for free to sign up go to
Skillshare comm slash brain again go to
Skillshare comm slash brain to start
your two months now that Skillshare
dot-com slash brain so but anyway back
to shout out I love both those guys so
much so that's my Justin I don't really
know you that well except for a few
times of your on set but I would gas you
up more but I don't know too much about
you all I know is that you a cute ass
[ __ ] did you know he's talented
Danu talented I haven't seen you in [ __ ]
yet so I will say this with him yeah but
that was that was it was some small [ __ ]
damn like I haven't seen him seen him so
I think yeah Bono is it from what I saw
I have a picture of him that's like cute
well when after yang camp comes out then
you can was after yang about it's about
this like AI robot which is Justin plays
the robot to say I Robot and get to
adopted into a family he's it's with
Colin Farrell oh girl oh girl he plays
opposite Colin Farrell he will come for
Elsa dad yeah man oh man he had a sex
date that was really weird dude he had a
weird yeah he has some weird [ __ ] dude
yo shot yo you're working with Colin
Farrell bro I think I can say that I
think that God announced Boop's I'm
pretty sure after yang sounds really
familiar to me it's it was somewhere on
deadline I'm pretty sure what about you
dude
who you trying to be positive and give a
shout-out to right now you know man
that's um you know I'll give it out to
Dante Dante Basco every time I need you
know help with anything or just like
just just late night talks about just
life and you know correcting my
negativity about you know the business
and some of the unfortunate [ __ ] that
happens to me he was helps me find a
light in this so he has a photography
business headshots check him out he's
always helpful with the newcomers in
town hashtag jive duck hashtag jive duck
so yeah vendor Swain dude Dante is one
of those nice ass dudes man like every
time he talks he makes me feel like I
live a life of sin he is so [ __ ] nice
man there was a good everything about
him is just nice I don't think he has a
evil thought I don't even think he
masturbates dude how about that this guy
looks [ __ ] pure as hell dude yeah he
looks timeless you know he's a he's one
of the nicest guys I've ever met in LA
his voice so yeah so great and the
biggest smile mm-hmm a handsome guy I'll
do all these people you gotta shout
you're handsome is [ __ ] me yeah he's
super [ __ ] - I mean I saw him in like
Wong foo stuff right and I was like man
this guy's [ __ ] dope dude yeah I
finally got to do a sketch with him it's
actually the first time me and him have
AK working yeah I think that's the first
time you and him have ever worked
together he's me he's helped me a bunch
of times with auditions but I've never
actually done is that dude nah they
weren't gonna sketch with me once I
oh yeah back in the day yeah wait Khalif
have we ever done anything we've never
actually worked together Zephir jab I'm
gonna write something for you guys
tomorrow and it's going to be a sexy
[Laughter]
she's gonna [ __ ] you against the wall
she's just gonna grab you by your fro
and bang your head
no oh wait actor Billy I was gonna say
but that's not really no we didn't but
we never acted together
no yeah we did a photo shoot for Tiger
belly if you guys were to act together
what would that be like what would that
seem be like would it be more serious
would it be comedy comedy it would be
comedy and it would probably be some I
feel like me and you could do a pretty
funny stoner comedy yeah so I could
totally see that like some kind of like
weird retelling of Harold and Kumar but
it's me and you yeah exit that yeah like
some random yeah like adventure
maybe maybe less Harold and Kumar more
pineapple Express I like that yeah like
like we really get into some like crazy
[ __ ] right he'd be the boss and he's not
in it he's not casting it that's
perfectly fine I don't care to do maybe
I'll just do a sex scene by myself dude
we walk into David having sex with some
kind of animal but it's just us tripping
out cuz we're stoned sure but then like
plot twist it's real it's real like it's
David having sex with myself this is the
weirdest video I've ever seen in my
[ __ ] life yeah damn straight
that'll make it pop and it happened ninh
dude yeah what's this movie called dude
it's called a night with myself
[Laughter]
exactly let me Who am I gonna shout out
in in the acting world man that I
haven't already shouted out right oh it
doesn't have to be acting world well I
thought we shouted now actors a shakers
you were shouting out actors well film
he's in film we started off with just
anyone just happened to go in that door
oh so I could just shout out anybody
yeah
shoutout to the Fon Bros you ready
shouted them out stop giving them so
much love okay I'm just a big fan of
theirs dude
babies they just breaking it down all
Asian people are a certain way and
that's the only way that they are did I
love it man I can't wait to hear the
real story about this no I love story
big fans of theirs dude already [ __ ]
Arnie man Arnie and donk
so I don't know what you're talking
about
there's a crazy crazy dude just next to
the people who have paved the way for me
yeah I would be nothing without these
guys see that's how I know you're lying
because the David I know would be like
nobody paved the way from me I paved the
way but no people have paved the way for
me to be Who I am right now okay William
Hung also one of my heroes William Hung
paved the way for me to shut out shout
outs to William Hung dude because he got
a million dollar [ __ ] music music
contract and without him doing that I
would have I would never be the person
that I am
shoutout to that actor dude in [ __ ] a
2 broke girls the one that plays the
little the little engine but no man to
wait Matthew mm oh no Mike beau the way
he represents Asian people Paul - man I
love him so much thank you
I hate David so so much right now did
you like unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt I
have not seen an episode of that is he
on there no oh if he was he probably
wouldn't really were you gonna bring up
um why am i blinking on his name no you
were gonna bring up no one from that was
that references like that okay
shout out to Bobby [ __ ] Lee man
that's the rule on the real [ __ ] dude
like I love Bobby Lee you people don't
realize how much I love Bobby Lee right
I wish I knew him better
like Bobby Lee is like one of those
dudes that because I listen to tiger
belly all the [ __ ] time right and
Bobby Lee is one of those guys that I
wanted to be on MADtv because of him
like it was one of my life goals before
it got canceled like I wanted to be a
MADtv cast member Dante Basco
huh dr. bass go and see you guys daddy
Bosco I I only need Dante Bosco from the
hood film and then oh no there's a few
other films too but hook was the one
that stood out to me the most but he was
in the comic so like Bobbie Lee just
watch for example I didn't really know
that the people in MADtv were like
stand-up comics until way later right
because as a kid you just see these guys
that are doing funny sketches on TV and
then I saw him do stand-up and do it it
blew my [ __ ] mind specifically
because I saw his nutsack I've seen that
man's ball sack so many times in my life
it's unreal dude I I will say that I
would love to know him better oh you
will never in the get to know him but
he's a crazy person but yeah well that's
why because he's like he's such a
fascinating unicorn there's truly no one
in the world like him he's so genuinely
[ __ ] funny dude yeah I don't give a
[ __ ] like it's like he he's just and his
comedy is so unique to me like nobody's
doing Bobby Lee's style comedy at all
yeah and that's what I'd like about him
he's not a very generic Asian comic and
that's what I love that about Bobby Lee
the most that's why to me he's up there
for me he was a guest on this Food Show
that I recently shall I did that to is
the ramen one oh yeah yeah that was
funny you the best [ __ ] you're hot
you're spicy ramen child that cut was
[ __ ] terrible man where the [ __ ] is
all this [ __ ] should have never been on
this thing like that was the first time
I think I saw him in person I didn't I
didn't shoot that segment with him so I
didn't really talk to him but you're
just watching him in person is
fascinating he's awesome absolutely
fascinating I love that guy dude which
is why I wanted like he just makes me so
curious about who he is it's because I
look up to that guy and people people
are like out of all the people I'm like
do I look up to Bobby Lee he's like yes
all his quirks and he may have all his
flaws but he's super open with it I
[ __ ] [ __ ] look up I get it I get
it
I like him as an actor too I loved it
love he's dope yeah people don't know
people sleep on Bobby Lee don't you dare
sleep on the slab can you see I could be
positive I guess everybody who else you
want me to gas up I'll gas up a [ __ ] ton
of people your fianc
oh I cast up all the time let's how
about you gas up a female person who's a
I know there's so many there's actually
dude it's fascinating
I'm fascinating is the word apparently
of this podcast no because I grew up
with having mostly guy friends and I
used if I was about you mom dude if I
did get picked on you I was picked on by
girls for sure I feel like every time a
girl saw a girl hang out with guys
they're just like they're running trains
on that [ __ ] I just like naturally got
along better with guys I mean I I was
very very tomboyish growing up and I
still have a lot of that blood in me but
like yeah I don't know and if I if I did
have a girlfriend it would be like one
and she also would be someone who also
got along really well with guys yeah but
like the older I got I think I just
learned how important it is as a female
to have strong female friends so I have
many many a female friends to shout out
I can gas up Ellen Kim because I know
your shout outs to Ellie Ellie hey
shockingly known for gosh I think it's
been on ten years or ten years and over
now and the fact that we cuz we met when
I still lived in New York and I was yeah
I was I was already dancing in New York
and I remember her when she was part of
the lost kids I don't know if you
remember any of this she was part of a
crew called the lost kids and they came
out for a dance event and like taught
workshops and stuff and that was the
first time that I met her and like we
hung out all weekend and like became
really good friends and then we just
kept in touch throughout all the years
and then she finally moved to LA and
then I remember I like drove her to
Target and somehow got lost in North
Hollywood even though I'd been living in
Hollywood for like like a year at that
point but ya know she's like been one of
my longest friends and like definitely a
nearly blood sister for real and like
just I've her hustle is probably one of
the most insane hustles that I've been
able to witness yeah like you want to
talk about someone who works hard that
that girl works hard and and I freaking
love her daughter kaya so there's
another female to shout out my friend
Phoebe from New Zealand who is
incredible and has been like bedrock to
my life and my friend Anna Kim from
Australia you sound like numbers in
[ __ ] the Bible right now like god
damn dude I said one person she was like
Abraham the son of Jedi can shout out
cuz I have a lot of great females in my
life right now you ain't all about the
boys man not not anymore yeah I mean I
still have like my close guy friends but
I've definitely come to have like a
great group of girlfriends in my life
which I'm very very happy about and
proud of that's dope though is I mean
see I actually like this whole shout out
thing because it's like it really does I
don't I don't think a lot of people get
to say this to people in person because
it feels weird right yeah it's very odd
you know I mean to come up to somebody
and be like yo man let me tell you
somehow dope you are right it's it's a
safe I don't know it feels socially
awkward to me is it I actually do it all
the time yeah that's why you have no
friends that's the thing like I don't
think we do it enough so I often do like
will randomly text or message friends
and tell them why I think they're all
yeah for sure I'm saying I'm what I'm
saying is for like a lot of people don't
do it because it does feel weird right
Sharon and I think like it's just also
too because some people don't want to
say it because they're wondering if
somebody will say something like that
back to them so they'd rather just leave
that sure you just got to do it without
any expectation emotive intention
exactly that's coming through cuz it's
like cuz everyone's in the same like you
just everyone's go-go-go but you need to
stop appreciate the moment like I see
you you see me hopefully and then you
know move on he would just don't are two
down I'm scared to stop well that's why
I'm starting a
from kind of trend but it's I mean
what's the trend yeah what is this dress
oh just like drop this isn't going back
to me being a joy BOM joy Bongo Joe I
mean I just think people like you know
you never know what people are going
through and I think a lot of times we
just it's nice to be reminded of like oh
yeah I don't suck at life
and so I like to remind people why
they're awesome especially the ones in
my life and it's not because I need you
to say it back to me everybody needs a
little Amanda Sookie huh I think so but
it is also just generally very important
because I can't tell you the number of
times that someone was like dude that's
so crazy that you messaged me I was
actually like going through whatever
thing so thank you for sending this to
me because I was like having a really
hard day and like that's without me
having no idea like what was going on I
just like I don't know I felt like if I
haven't talked to someone in like a week
I'm like she's a message you know that's
true though I was eating at this one
spot I was so stupid when I say it but I
was eating at this one joint rights as
Japanese doing and this one girl I
actually respond to her on the DMS all
the time her name is Teresa go shout
outs to Teresa go Teresa go I don't know
what kind of funk I was in but I was
like in like a very weird this is like
after [ __ ] and I didn't know what I
wanted to do because honestly with that
whole Sunday and should happen I didn't
expect to get that far and I was like
okay well there was like a goal that I
was planning to do in 10 years I'm gonna
happen overnight and it's like a weird
thing where's the site oh [ __ ] I didn't
plan be that what after right now that
well is that kind of this weird fog and
this girl Teresa she just came up to me
didn't ask for anything she goes hey I
bought you your meal I just want to say
thank you you know for our outside and I
just felt so good to a picture with her
I shouted her out because like that made
me feel really [ __ ] good that's
amazing Teresa you were you were angel
days ago I mean let me tell you where I
eat my meal yeah she's like
I mean I don't have a film at Sundance
but yeah that was two years ago keratin
now I just like to bring it up he shoved
it everybody facing down there just
kidding what about you
me what female shoutout female shoutout
[Music]
why would I ever show man dad can't say
your mom can't say my mom me I tell you
man let's see ya are you are you lacking
in females in your life yeah I guess so
friends yeah what's have to say huh yeah
huh damn I got no female friends home
you know like significant impact know
what about about how about someone who's
not a friend I mean cuz like this person
wasn't technically a friend who Teresa
go okay she's a [ __ ] friend how dare
you how dare you minimize losses in my
life this is why she wouldn't ever buy
you a meal she would spit in the floor
well good thing I don't need fun what do
you eat then I'm just shouting out like
there's people who like you're just
we're doing hold on a second bro don't
be [ __ ] trying to get off on this
[ __ ] you better shout out one [ __ ]
female if not the [ __ ] comments one
okay all right cool the shoutouts we're
gonna title to [ __ ] the shoutouts to
shoutouts um can I say Sydney Sydney
whoo bye oh yeah you can say shout out
the city from Casa pine Meg Sydney from
Sydney Ramos why cuz she man when she
will say she still working there right
now she's not gonna get that wrong in
there see that's how this is that's how
how impactful she is at this restaurant
at cosine qasim PI and South Pasadena
what made her so memorable for you cuz
she like remember in my order but before
that she just has energy it's just sweet
very warm just it's an early morning
just it's the gur it's the right amount
of positivity to start you on your
all right she get great hugs - hugs so
so there's a spot so when I used to live
in South Pasadena it was like pretty
close to where I lived
it was his joint called cos and pie when
they opened up so there used to be this
old sandwich shop that used to be there
and you know for back in the day it was
probably good right and it was a little
bit old slightly dilapidated you know
just not not it wasn't doing too well
but they took over the spot and I was
there like the first thing that they
ever opened up and the moment I bit into
their food I was like this place is
going to be [ __ ] poppin because in
that specific area where cost and pious
there aren't really in many other
restaurants yeah not at all and so I was
like mmm
okay I'm not gonna tell anybody about
this [ __ ] but word of mouth got out and
that place is [ __ ] popping all the
time thanks to you
where the mouth got out I mean I learned
about it from you yeah well at that
point they were already popping so I was
like I'm just gonna tell everybody no
but I did a video for them and
everything but cos and pide they just do
the reason why I like that establishment
so much is because they truly and
genuinely enjoy food and you could taste
it in the stuff that they do they have a
they don't have a crazy extensive menu
but with the stuff that they do have
they do really well and they're a burger
brunch place when in your mind is kind
of like how great can a burger brunch
place be but they just do great things
like for example they do a spam and egg
sandwich mm-hmm house-made spam soft
scrambled eggs in house-made brioche bun
by the by the co-owner and baker Sochi
Sochi love Sochi did a shout out yeah
man
Casey to her husband the man who is the
the chef behind everything the guy puts
like so much love attention and detail
into his food and him you know it just
it makes me very happy
yeah I love watch it haven't described
as food and it's like the little dinner
events yeah he's like this he's happy
yeah that's that's the type of vibe I
like that's you know that's who I'm I
know people want me to shout out Mariel
but I do it all of them I love Mary oh I
could talk about Monroe for three four
thousand [ __ ] hours so we're not
gonna do that
I just love you very much but Sochi is
also somebody that I really appreciate
including her husband as well just
because I like being around people who
are passionate about the stuff that they
do and when you when you're around those
type of human beings it really gives you
your own type of gas beside damn dude
look at this [ __ ] he's talking
about why
and how it pairs with his types of food
why he chose his food why it's important
to him in he could talk about it to the
my new [ __ ] detail and that just goes
to show which I don't see a lot in a lot
of younger people nowadays because
there's a lot of clout chasing ya if
somebody to do somebody that does
something simply because they love it
whether you get an external
gratification in terms of like you
create it first for yourself and the
external crowd of vacation comes after
so the initial reason why you created
something wasn't to please everybody
else it was to police his palate first
yeah which we don't
I think that's starting to disappear a
lot and that's the general direction
that people are going so even when
people create content now it's not do I
like this does this make me laugh is
does this relate to everybody else will
it make them laugh yeah
will it get me the numbers that I it
makes me sad and that's why we see a lot
of repetitious things how many [ __ ]
times do especially when vine came out
they were here don't touch my girlfriend
what you know it's like oh my [ __ ]
god dude like how many times can I see
the same [ __ ] troll dude I feel
uncool cuz I don't think I ever
downloaded vine and or no but I think
that's why I like Sochi so much when she
talks about the food like she so they
originally were going to open up to do
dinners right and I was gas for it
because whatever passion that they put
into the brunch and breakfast food I
knew it was gonna happen with their
dinner right and I couldn't remember
what it was called because I think it's
like a lot it's like cotton or isn't
like that that's right yeah I forgot
yeah yeah but it just it was so [ __ ]
good it was kind of like cooked into
like this sauce that was like every part
of the pig there was like pork rinds
there was ribs there was just belly
there was everything cheeks everything I
could think of and it was cooked in like
a pot or some [ __ ] like that but it was
something that that's culturally close
to her right and I I've never had it
before and you get to taste that type of
passion dude and I was super hyped and
happy for them and every time we have a
conversation with her
she's so gassed about her food is a
culturally where's she from
thanks good she's not I don't know what
part of Mexico but whatever she served
us I've never had it before it was
it was so [ __ ] good though what's
your what what's a new favorite
restaurant you have now before Koston
pie a shout out to Haley - she works
there she's oh oh shout outs to Haley do
all your females are closed and pie
people shout outs to Haley [ __ ]
because they open up around the time we
move moved in there right kind of kind
of not really they were like they feel
like been the neighbors like yeah they
it was like a year after we moved in
there so because I was going to that
sandwich shop because there was nothing
else to eat around there so I that's why
I was eating but they had they had like
chilaquiles there [ __ ] so I knew they
kind of mixed it up every now and then
but uh yeah do you have any other
favorites though to like put me on - oh
that's hard to say I have it I've been
traveling a lot for food so I haven't
been able oh yeah yeah you're like a
legit foodie guy there's like I don't
know if I'm a foodie per se just a fad
do that eats but there's like la técnica
it's it's it's a derivative it's a it's
a derivative of tacos iberia la única
also [ __ ] delicious do so they do
they do goat tacos right so be dia and
so they'll dip it into this consomme
brought that they cook slow cook the
goat in and they take also the oil and
the juices and they pan fry it over like
a skillet and inside is like the beauty
of Mead there's like a sow in there just
with a little bit of like [ __ ] cotija
cheese crumbled on top and you where's
this this is out in there's one in North
Hollywood really close to us and then
the other one is out in East LA
in the heart of uh yeah you stole a also
like cuz I've been into like a lot of
like like cheaper truck foods right yeah
just because like there's something
about it just so [ __ ] delicious
there's no frills to it and the food is
just really good right
so like mariscos Jalisco love that place
dude there's shrimp tacos Dorados
[ __ ] delicious
Avenue 26 the best dollar taco spot yet
love Avenue 26 yeah single dollars like
I like them because they're a dollar and
there's also like tire shop tunnels that
I talked about - there's a bunch of
spots dude like I I personally love the
street mystery
my street foods like [ __ ] would you if
you ever had a food truck would you do
Mexican probably no because I would
bastardize that [ __ ] I don't think I've
grown up around the food enough to have
a good palate for it that's the problem
right so even when sometimes when I cook
other types of food that's outside of
Asian food I eat it and I'm like it's
okay and I don't know what it is is
because I think
well what I'm surmising is that it's
because I didn't grow up eating it my
whole life yeah yeah so when it comes to
Korean food I'd like my Korean food a
lot just because I grew up eating Korean
food every [ __ ] day Japanese food
whatever but when it comes to those type
of foods that are something that's newly
introduced to me I maybe be able to put
a spit onto it but I'm not sure that
I'll be able to create something that I
want to keep around and serve to people
for sure that's the hard part for me
right
so shoutouts to Sochi Sochi
and Sydney Bailey yeah well I we have a
not my roommate anymore but this is a
guy named Ray Ray's the man dude
actually I'll tell you this right now I
actually was trying to take ray with me
when I left that's how much I love ray
take him take him with you where to move
in with me oh my Muriel said no what's I
don't know so tell me what's okay right
right okay let me just tell you
something real quick about tell me some
Raymond [ __ ] Park aka reggae ka
who what else red killer ray Killa
Raymundo
actually known ray since I was like 2
years old right ray has been ray is
always one of those dude we call him the
silent but deadly [ __ ] killer
dude he's always quite this [ __ ]
don't sit I've never seen him sit in my
life yeah he never sits stands all the
[ __ ] time but he's like that type of
roommate super clean always comes in
with those slight little jokes never
really expected
if something's busted in the house the
next day you best believe ray Killa
fixed it doesn't even have to be asked
takes out the trash does everything
that's kind of roommate love ray to
death I wanted to take him with me
Muriel said no she says sister story is
that one a bit yes I was trying to take
him with legit and I was legit kind of
jealous like over he doesn't leave is he
still with you yeah he's okay yep I've
known him since I was two two years old
in Sacramento California the same church
we went to he went to UC Davis I went to
UCR and then when I moved back to LA he
actually moved back at the same time and
lo and behold I got in to move in with
me and I kept I held onto him for
[ __ ] six years this lady named Ariel
song comes around and strips him away
from me is he single is he cute he is
single and I love ray let me tell you
something you don't deserve him you're
too damaged for him like damaged girls
don't makes things more exciting
yeah we like we like dents in our cars
we don't want the engine missing hey
missing I might have a crack or two in
the transmission by I might need my oil
changed by Ray is a unique guy that like
you have to get to know him to
understand his humor and he's super
quiet but once you get him to speak and
he opens up man
ray is funny been like I love ray he's a
very simple guy to you you want to talk
about minimalist he's a minimalist yeah
so if you [ __ ] with minimalist racing
the type of guy if Ray falls in love
with you just best belief he has
everything in your best interest he
takes care of me till this day if Mary
old eyes I'm never gonna get back with
somebody ever again I'm going to be
great right me and Ray will be single
till the death of us I'm actually
speaking for him I don't care if you
find that we're we're together now I
think I've just fallen in love to erase
great dude I [ __ ] love ray man right
man you have been with me since I was a
hoodlum and he still stuck around
shout-out to Ray Ray Park
Raymond Killa dude Raymond but you had
that type of relationship with [ __ ] but
once
Megan butuan that's a French name mega
[ __ ] Juan seguín butuan oh yeah how did
you and Merritt up Mariel make it meat
we love telling this story I was
actually really mean to her the first
time we about what a Korean [ __ ] yeah I
was in her eyes basically in the dance
culture there's like a thing that we
like to call groupies
and I just based off of who Megan was
hanging out with when I first met her I
just kinda sumed she was one too and we
were at this house party in Vegas
shoutout to jr. Akeno is his house
oh the singer is a very fantastic scene
yeah amazing singer we were all at his
house and I think it was actually my
birthday week to where we were all in
Vegas for HHI which is this big hip-hop
competition and yeah she was at this
house party as well this is back when I
had like shaved sides and stuff and she
yeah yeah dude dude I used to have a
pixie cut bleached platinum blonde I had
a face for sure and then yeah so Megan
was at this party and she comes up to me
she's like hey I really like your
haircut and me thinking she was just
another groupie I was like yeah it's the
same as yours and then walked away damn
what a [ __ ] I was a mean girl I was a
mean girl and then fast forward one year
later I was running movement life style
at the time and she had just moved to LA
and she was taking some classes at the
studio and I don't know I think I just
forgot that that happened and we were
getting along she's I think she brought
up she's like yeah we actually met last
year party and I was like I was like
sorry I don't remember and she kind of
like refreshed my memory and she like
jokingly brought up the story about the
haircut and I was like oh my god I
totally remember I'm so sorry that I was
mean to you because I really liked her
in in this environment and so just
judged them all I really did and then
you know mm-hmm I think like that
same week or like the next week I had
put up on my facebook that I was looking
for a roommate and she hit me up and I
was like yeah I come check out the place
if you are interested and then yeah just
look together yeah and then we lived
together in that particular apartment
for five years
the one where I did that ghetto ass [ __ ]
yeah talk show oh yeah actually right
if there's anybody that's resourceful
it's that girl you want to talk about it
come up dude
yeah that's to Megan she definitely came
up yeah yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] lady won't
come on my talk show I saw I was like yo
talk about rinky-dink dude yeah it's
crazy
you saw the video it doesn't look good
because I'm saying like [ __ ]
she knows how to make something out of
nothing for sure yeah yeah so we lived
in that apartment for four years and
then we moved to another apartment oh no
I think that apartment was four or five
years in another apartment for one year
so but we've known each other for now
maybe seven you guys split what was that
like it was fascinating it was a such a
growth experience for the both of us
like for me it I had already lived by
myself
prior to this apartment with her so I've
had experience living on my own but she
had never at this point and so she just
really wanted to know what it was like
to live by herself and yeah be an
independent woman and so it was like
yeah it was like we're not gonna live
together forever so it was about time
and you guys had that friend's moment
where Monica we took a picture in our
empty apartment so we're so corny we set
up the camera and it was like I think we
were like hugging each other and it's
like we set up like a self-timer camera
with this empty apartment which was like
a couple of boxes you know it was fun
but we've had like in terms of roommates
it was like the easiest thing ever like
because she loves to cook and I love to
cook we would always like make random
meals she like back then when I was more
involved in the dance community I had so
many people constantly like looking for
places to stay and she never once
complained about me having like people
overall but like I was that girl that
always had people over I would have
killed you oh I was really looking to
admit like hey you [ __ ] maniac yeah
get these [ __ ] homeless people out of
my house these waters not homeless
squatter she never she never complained
like there at one point like there was
this entire crew of Aussie boys that I
knew that they were all in LA for I
forget why I we had four or five Aussie
boy dancers you would talk about smelly
guys and she like didn't care that I
gave them a place to stay how many days
I don't remember it was so long ago how
many days maybe a week lost your [ __ ]
mind
that's how cool she was terrible
roommate you want that's how cool she is
that felt terrible you are in a person
hey no we we were great roommates I mean
that's why we lived together for so long
it's just a it worked out so well you
what here's the [ __ ] plot twist it's
like I just want to live on Milo's like
no you don't know that one time you
bought those [ __ ] four guys over
I spent let me say something this is now
this is how I am as a person my thing is
like when we when we live together
there's certain rules that we have right
like the great thing about like me and
Cleveland we live together we never had
anybody over like like house is like
home base for us right occasionally we
will bring on one or two people over but
they wouldn't be staying for [ __ ]
long right because our this is our spot
we got it we got a destress here right
so I had a roommate that didn't
understand that boundary I and we all
agreed on to the gym module in this
place that we lived out very expensive
and he played the least amount of rent
its muhfucka at the south pass place
notice the LA yeah tell ma [ __ ] like so
it was very expensive joint and he just
I just saw these dudes come at the door
and like oh yeah he said that we could
stay here for a week we're visiting I'm
like he doesn't pay a lot of rent here
so you're gonna have to stay outside
until I until he comes here and I went
close the door on them and then he came
in I was like so what's up I was like
you saying these dudes could stay over
right it was like yeah they're friends
from you know back at home I'm like
that's cool you pay nothing here dude so
what makes you think that all of us all
the rest four of our roommates have to
make an adjustment for these people we
don't [ __ ] know yeah I was like you
go aside you tell them that they have to
go find a hotel or somewhere else to
stay and he had to go out and he did it
well see that's the difference here is
he invited these people without asking
you guys first even if he did that we
all would have collectively said no but
at least he would have asked and so
Megan I apologize for all the people
that I ever had over but I always asked
Megan well yeah that would have that
actually would have been ten times
better if you had asked us ahead of time
just showed up at the door exactly
that's totally different cuz then again
you're made to look out like the [ __ ]
by saying no had he asked you first and
it would have been like yeah for sure I
don't have a problem with that I don't
have a problem saying no at all knows my
favorite word but that being said I
really did for that period of time enjoy
having people over all the time but like
now I I wouldn't be like that but this
is like when we're young and like pooped
in your head we were young and we were
free and we were careless and you know
it's just it was fun to have like be the
hostel no it's not a dance you would
wake up with a dance in the dance world
back then this is like before people
were traveling and like or taking care
of choreographers and putting them up in
like hotels and stuff like even when I
used to live in New York them will pop
lock on Santa Monica just dance your ass
off at the [ __ ] hotel [ __ ] no
because like in college fact like when I
was in at NYU I was on a dance team and
we would host workshops and we would
want to fly choreographers at but we're
at college team we're not funded by NYU
so yeah we had to like figure out money
ourselves so like not only are we paying
your rate we also like we find out
lodging we can't afford your rate and a
hotel like that's like crazy time like
crazy talk at the time cuz this is
before the dance industry really blew up
and like this is a norm now we're like
choreographers are really treated like
real artists and like being put up in
these nice hotels and have writers and
things like that so like me as a college
student having to be resourceful we'd
have to figure it out so like I lived in
the city and so whenever we wanted to
fly choreographers in I would house them
in my living room and like they slept on
our like futon in my living room I
person do well it in hindsight it's also
like I'm sorry we have such shitty
accommodations but like our hotel
apartment was like a pretty decent
apartment it wasn't like a dingy New
York apartment so it's like kind of nice
like at one point I remember I had a
bunch of friends on Kaba modern like
literally half of them the guys had to
sleep on the floor
way back when I don't know if you're
familiar with Ian Eastwood yes he has
really really large lips like
excessively large like it looks like the
candy lips that's a very interesting
observation well that's like half his
face [ __ ] face about it acknowledge
its that he's a very pretty boy like
listen man my the most heterosexual
thing about me is all acknowledged when
another man is [ __ ] beautiful his
[ __ ] and he got these luscious ass lips
if he went to prison he'd be the number
one pick Wow well I was skin is what he
looks like yes he was one of the first
choreographers we paid to fly out to New
York for a workshop but this was back
when he was still like super super young
I think he was only like 15 or 16 so his
dad had to come out as well cuz you know
he's not allowed to travel by himself
yet and so we but the dad paid for his
own flight but like because at the time
we're housing all these choreographers
in our apartment like him and his dad
slept in our freakin living room on the
futon for like three two nights the
hotel
well no I mean it's because like we were
paying for them so I don't type of
situation enough or something I think
that culture though of those times is
why like when I moved the early years of
when I moved out to LA I'm like seeing
all these like that's just what we were
used to like Dan dancers don't make a
lot of money so like we're how can we
all help each other out and so like I
just got used to like you're just so
[ __ ] nice man I don't have that [ __ ]
in me just like you said a horrible
roommate yeah you just a horrible
[ __ ] roommate but it was a lot of fun
times like when you're young and
careless like this is it's all fun you
know like we all party anyway no I do
understand too because I'm clearly
[ __ ] joking but Ari no yeah and back
in the day like my buddy Dan like he's
very successful now but whenever you
came from Seattle he would sleep in our
living room yeah when because needed a
place to crash it was stay there for
like two two weeks three weeks I'd time
or whatever and common if not four
people definitely one person two people
maybe at most four people I don't know
what you're trying know but me and Megan
had some really great times living
together so you
not at all I mean a bunch of dancers in
the early years of me and Megan living
together we were both very messy so yes
it it oftentimes looked crazy but then
over the years especially Megan because
she became much more of a minimalist
that it like especially by the second
apartment we lived in together it was
always way more clean so yeah I mean it
was it was a lot of fun living together
so and if anything - by living with
Megan that's how I really came to
respect a lot of youtubers because I was
able to see firsthand how hard you guys
all actually work it's not just like I'm
gonna throw just Megan because Megan
works really hard you know I don't I
just sit on a couch and masturbate and
then I hope that a [ __ ] script idea
but yeah like between like her like
d-trix like all these people who shout
outs to Dominic's and balls man you know
he did the funniest video about him
balding dude best [ __ ] made me die
laughing dude I love people to make fun
of themselves very real I love that [ __ ]
dude and this [ __ ] do shoutouts
to that [ __ ] weirdo dude love that
little boy did he's hilarious man yeah
like just you know you see like how hard
like it's a full-on production and
they're like funding everything
themselves he likes funny a lot of stuff
they're doing on their own like teaching
themselves editing like all this crazy
stuff it's like you know you all you see
is this final product and it what looks
like just one person shooting something
oh that's a whole [ __ ] ordeal me and
it's like you know I really came to
respect you basically what you're saying
is that you've been a hater your whole
life no there's one person changed their
life and taught you how to not to be
hated YouTube because I didn't YouTube
didn't really exist before like I didn't
really learn about until me and Megan
lived together so I never came from a
place of hate when it came to YouTube I
just saw like what other people were
seeing and thinking that because I would
always hear comments of like oh why
don't you just become a youtuber it
sounds so easy like highways [ __ ] yeah
like English so many times people make
that kind of comment I'm like man if you
guys only knew how much hard work it
took like well it's just
everybody's on this like dick-measuring
game right they feel like they have to
trash what somebody else does to make
them feel better about what they're
doing why does it have to be like that
yeah why can't you be successful at what
you do and I could be successful at what
I do
III had to run into that situation all
the time so I owe you money you make
your own [ __ ] schedule too
I was like [ __ ] if you could do what I
do please [ __ ] do it yeah do it right
[ __ ] now but you can't like I can't
do what you do and I never pretend like
I can I never look at your career your
job is safe that's all that they [ __ ]
do never do I do that [ __ ] right
especially because I came from super
humble beginnings right so it's like how
where do people go off like looking at
what other people do and it's like it
really stems from a place of like I
wished that I was in your position and
maybe that's the case but there's also
stuff that comes along with it right you
see me do you - my whole life man you
know how [ __ ] stressful that [ __ ] is
mm-hmm
like just always staying up at night
trying to be on top yeah I tried to do
it my like I'm not it's just not in my
DNA like I couldn't yeah it's just it is
what it is man like I yeah I don't know
if everyone like works as hard as like
say you Megan Dom Brian Higgins Megan's
a beast though Mike Megan definitely
she's up there like she definitely works
a lot harder than mostly right because I
think there are like a fair share of
youtubers who do just like make a dumb
video and it goes like freakin viral and
then like that just becomes their mo
their stick and then like they blow up
into like the millions so yes there are
people like that who do exist but I will
I will passionately be like one of the
first people to defend like the
hard-working ones
oh yeah cuz Megan never really had him I
mean she has a few million hits but she
doesn't have really big bangers that
blew her up yeah it was a consistent
person yes highly consistent and the
great thing about her and actually use
Megan batoon as an example a lot when
people say that they want to be a
youtuber I was like a lot of you guys
focus too much on having millions of
views rather than really really catering
towards the people that really [ __ ] yeah
yeah as people who [ __ ] with Megan they
[ __ ] with her hard yeah and it's because
she really does this thing where she
relates to the people that care about
her and she focuses on that demographic
really really well so it's not about
having a million people follow you and
forget about she was about having that
good core strong people around you right
and that's that's what Megan does well
she called it I remember you saying that
before - that's a [ __ ] man like
that's why her merge sells out so
quickly all the time to like people like
want like they're part of her family
sure why not yeah well guys that wraps
another podcast
oh there's truly just a shout out
encouragement podcast yeah man sometimes
people need to hear that [ __ ] because
before we go I'm gonna shout out David
so though that's so disgusting shut the
[ __ ] so men will actually live like
right around the corner for me so she'll
be honest I guess by frequently just so
I can know good
you're just so breaking you're just good
at talking and just opening huh I
[ __ ] love it did you're welcome
yeah well what can they find you Amanda
um I mean I guess you can follow me on
Instagram hey Sookie stylist su ke iest
y le s please follow me because my
followers drop weekly by the hundred
[Laughter]
runways to no story though she's yeah
you should see my subscribers literally
drops by the hundreds on the weekly I
don't know why you're not showing [ __ ]
tits and ass I guess so sorry so if
that's what you're looking for um yeah
but yeah man uh Khalif boy where can
they find you yeah Instagram police Boyd
I did a Twitter thing it's hey
underscore California is it yeah is this
kha Li up cookie hornwood yeah I didn't
know you're on Twitter I'll find you on
Twitter yeah guys I just retweet all of
them I just like what he likes every
show we like the most
ratchet shoot everything right out to
Ricky yo I love ratchet oh shout out to
[ __ ] Ricky shuts dude funny [ __ ]
funny ass guy anyways guys you could
catch us on Spotify iTunes podcast any
type of audio platform out there leave
in the comments below what y'all think
about you shout out to everybody out
there and every genius brain
watch out theater genius brainy's men
y'all are the best dude I'm glad that
you guys are [ __ ] with us I'm glad
that you're [ __ ] with the podcast
because I know that when we decided to
turn this into a podcast thing people
like know what about the funny videos
you know man sometimes people just want
some conversations homie that's for
giving David something to do yeah thank
you because I just masturbating is just
gets really old and so on that weird
note I'll see you guys next time